2018 has been an intense year at the movies,
including everything from pulpy detective
fiction to bloody tales of revenge, and all
manner of nervy narratives in between. These
are the most disturbing movies of 2018.
Many people know Jonathan Ames as the creative
force behind HBO's short-lived comedy/detective
series Bored to Death, but he's also an incisive
writer of genre-hopping essays, novels, and
screenplays. For his 2013 novella You Were
Never Really Here, Ames crafted a corrosively
bleak piece of detective fiction about a troubled
war vet tasked with finding the kidnapped
13-year-old daughter of a U.S. senator.
Indie director and screenplay writer Lynne
Ramsay unleashed the slow-burning beast that
was the theatrical version of You Were Never
Really Here in the spring, changing very little
in adapting Ames' novel. Instead, Ramsay bolstered
the tightly-wound narrative with stylistic
flourishes that ratchet the tension to near-suffocating
extremes. The result is a frenzied, bloody,
deeply paranoid fever dream of a film that
hammers its way into your head like a nightmare
you won't easily wake from.
Hollywood loves a good tale of teenagers running
amok, and joining the ranks of tales of youthful
rebellion is Cory Finley's Thoroughbreds.
As far as tales of youthful rebellion go,
Finley's sly, bracingly immersive crime dramedy
is one for the ages.
Thoroughbreds follows two upper-class teens
who live on opposite ends of the human emotional
spectrum - one incapable of feeling anything,
while the other feels everything.
"I don't have any feelings ever."
When they're reunited after years apart, each
finds themselves in a position to help the
other right a perceived wrong. That help comes
at a high cost for each, and together the
teens hatch a violent plan to take control
of their rapidly spiraling lives.
The crime itself plays second fiddle to a
focus on the tragically inventive young minds
behind it, played by by Olivia Cooke and Anya
Taylor-Joy, whose performances draw you into
the comic and tragic sides of Finley's drama.
It all lends an exacting edge to the film's
final moments, which may leave you giggling
while also fighting a nasty chill in your
spine.
Coralie Fargeat's debut feature, set in the
sweltering Moroccan desert, is proof that
revenge is not always a dish best served cold.
Part survival story and part tale of righteous
vengeance, Revenge unfolds in a blood-soaked
narrative that uses the desert setting to
serve up a steamy helping of primal payback.
It begins when pampered American party girl
Jen's getaway with Richard is interrupted
after his pals show up early for a hunting
trip. The weekend pivots dramatically after
a deplorable act that leads Richard to leave
Jen for dead in the unforgiving desert. She
awakes to find herself in the midst of a deadly
cat and mouse chase, transformed from object
to avenger, leading to one of the best "hunters
become the hunted" narratives in recent memory.
It's brutal, bloody and inventive in ways
we can't go into without spoiling the fun.
Just know that the almost dialogue-free action
is guided to a final showdown that will leave
you absolutely shaken to the core.
Every so often, we get a scary movie that
transcends its genre roots. This year, that
movie is unquestionably Ari Aster's utterly
terrifying "family drama" Hereditary. The
less you know going in the better, but we
can say that this film begins dark, and Aster
spends the next hour tightening the screws
to an unbearable sense of atmospheric dread
before hitting you with one of the most shocking
moments in horror movie history.
You'll never see it coming, it'll shock you
in ways you've probably never experienced
in a movie, and as impossible as it may seem
when it happens, Hereditary then sets about
getting a whole lot darker. If you're tough
enough to stick with it, you'll be able to
brag to friends that you made it through one
of the best, most disturbing horror films
not just of 2018, but likely of all time.
Unfolding in a beautifully realized alternate
version of present-day Oakland, Sorry to Bother
You follows the story of a young black telemarketer
who experiences a meteoric rise to success
after uncovering his inner "white voice."
"As always, we’ll be getting that out to
you right away."
What follows is a hilarious, often horrifying
madcap farce that plays like a mashup of Being
John Malkovich and Get Out, only angrier and
more perceptive.
Sorry to Bother You may be chock full of comically
inspired moments, but it's absolutely venomous
in its presentation of gender and race relations
and economic structures, and it never misses
a beat as it pivots effortlessly from one
shocking moment to the next. Director Boots
Riley's cast doesn't miss a beat either, and
they keep Riley's politically charged, sci-fi
fantasia grounded in particularly hard-hitting
ways — though it may leave you wincing the
next time you see a horse, man.
Luca Guadagnino's Suspiria is a fresh, ferocious,
and surprisingly political take on Dario Argento's
bloody, brooding 1977 horror classic.  The
newest version of the twisted tale about an
enigmatic dancer being tormented by dark forces
actually bests the film that inspired it in
both scope and scares.
Suspiria's 2018 version also dances past Argento's
original in runtime, clocking in at a hefty
152 minutes, and is filled with welcome narrative
additions like character development and actual
dancing. It also tends to avoid blind bloodlust
in favor of mood and menace as well, ratcheting
up the tension with fiery flourishes of nightmarish
imagery that punctuate the gruesome acts of
violence throughout. Even if you've seen Argento's
Suspiria, you won't be prepared for the gritty,
grisly carnage Guadagnino brings to the table,
making his take not just one of the most ambitiously
unsettling remakes ever produced, but also
one of the best.
Mandy is a film whose atypical revenge narrative
certainly fits the B-movie mold even as it
mercilessly transcends expectations, made
even better by the fact that Nicolas Cage
plays a man hellbent on avenging the murder
of his lover. Somehow, Mandy ended up being
one of the most memorable films in Cage's
filmography.
"So what you huntin'?"
"Crazy evil!”
It's what director Panos Cosmatos does within
this construct that makes the film so uniquely
disquieting, peppering the action with a murderous
cult of hippies led by a folk-singing wannabe
demigod. Throw in a demonic biker gang, hallucinatory
narcotics, surrealistic imagery, and enough
fake blood to float an ark, and you've earned
a spot in the vaunted "cult classic" canon.
Yes, Mandy is every bit the B-movie it seems,
but it's also one of the most visually striking,
vividly realized, and wholly original films
of the year, and its unbridled insanity simply
must be seen to be believed. Cage crazier
than usual? Crazier than this?
"A B C D E F G H I J K L M N O P Q R S!"
“Not the bees! Ahhhh! Oh they’re in my
eyes!"
"T U V W X Y Z! HUH!"
Now that's saying something.
When author Jeff VanderMeer published Annihilation,
it became an instant classic of modern science
fiction literature, and an easy target for
a big-screen adaptation. Fans of the book
were even more excited when hearing that Alex
Garland was handling that adaptation. After
months of delays and behind the scenes troubles,
Annihilation finally arrived in theaters…
except it didn't exactly stick to the source
material.
Garland took some serious liberties with the
story to craft a narrative all his own, but
his Annihilation works as both a direct adaptation
and a wholly original story that's every bit
as effective, horrifying, and emotionally
charged as the book. Garland even bests VanderMeer's
source material when it comes to scares, with
a blood-curdling bear/woman beast that serves
as one of the most unsettling creature creations
of this or any year. If only Garland had left
the door open for a sequel, we might've gotten
to see even more of his haunting, unearthly
delights.
With no fewer than a couple dozen or so films
utilizing social media's "like/share" obsession
as a plot device, Robert Mockler's sobering
drama Like Me is nothing like the rest. In
fact, this incisive feature debut is not like
any film you've ever seen before.
From its jarring opening moments, Mockler's
film is clearly out to shock. His tragic tale
of a young woman broadcasting her crime spree
across social media is part road movie, part
hallucinatory crime thriller, opening with
an attention-grabbing heist and ending with
brutal violence. The moments in between find
a hushed and harried character study.
Vivid photography and kaleidoscopic editing
ensure that even the film's muted moments
come and go with galvanizing energy. That
manic mix of styles makes Like Me the sort
of soul-crushing, spirited film you simply
cannot unsee… so make sure that you do.
After unleashing his sweaty-palmed action
epic The Raid in 2011, and following it up
with the equally bonkers The Raid 2, Gareth
Evans proved himself to be a master of both
staging and human drama.
So there was good reason to be excited when
Netflix announced they'd be producing Evans'
new film Apostle, which saw the director tackling
the horror genre. The result was a period
thriller about a troubled man tasked with
retrieving his sister from a creepy, island-dwelling
religious cult who worship a bloodthirsty
deity.
For the first hour, the movie swings a hypnotically
unholy pendulum before viewers' eyes, giving
Apostle with a near-suffocating gothic energy.
And then, Evans spends the next hour smashing
that pendulum into bloody bits, making you
long for the time when a bloodthirsty deity
was all you had to fear. Expect dastardly
deeds, unspeakably gruesome acts, fantastically
grotesque imagery, and a soul-choking sense
of dread. You'll be glued to the screen for
every nightmarish moment.
We're in a virtual golden age of genre mashups,
and one amazing example of this is the gloriously
unhinged World War II horror thriller Overlord.
Few other 2018 films arrive as well equipped
to delight and disturb in equal measure.
Odds are you've heard Overlord categorized
as a "nazi zombie horror flick", which is
only a little bit misleading. Yes, there are
lots of evil nazis, and the dead aren't always
exactly dead, but we can tell you there's
a lot more more going on here than meets the
eye.
The film - set on the eve of D-Day - is an
excellent World War II movie, opening with
a harrowing parachute drop behind enemy lines,
following a band of soldiers on a suicide
mission that will turn the tide of the war.
That mission leads them to a French village
teeming with nazi soldiers and scientists.
Without spoiling the film, just know that
the stomach-churning things uncovered in there
is the stuff of nightmares. Overlord is the
action-packed, blood-soaked war/horror hybrid
we never knew we needed.
After bursting into Hollywood as the scribe
behind the legendary film Taxi Driver, Paul
Schrader has continued to make a name for
himself as a screenwriter of unyielding vision…
and some very specific opinions about the
world at large. Schrader has also directed
his share of classics, with titles like American
Gigolo, Affliction, and Auto Focus. He returned
to the director's chair this year to unleash
First Reformed, reminding us that he's still
got plenty to say about the state of society.
Schrader's latest is a politically charged
narrative of societal despair, environmental
calamity, and righteous indignation. It pits
a well-intentioned priest against a world
where moral duplicity has led to big business
corrupting not just society, but also the
environment and the church. Anchored by a
career-best performance from Ethan Hawke,
First Reformed is a desolate piece of work
driven by insightful writing, unforgettable
imagery, and an atmospheric energy that teeters
ever on the edge of horror. It's also a bone-chilling
call to arms that we can only hope has not
come too late.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about messed-up
movies are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.